[Musique]
bonsoir je suis la première femme
exhibitionniste sexuelle en france
alors je vous préviens tout de suite
j'ai jamais agressé d'enfants où je me
balade pas complètement à poil sous un
imper dans le métro mais pourtant en
décembre 2014
j'ai été condamné pour exhibition
sexuelle par le tribunal de grande
instance de paris
à un mois de prison avec sursis et 3500
euros damende pour ça c'était la
première fois qu'une femme avait été
condamnée pour ce délit et ça donc comme
vous pouvez le voir c'est moi à l'église
de la madeleine à paris en décembre 2013
à l'époque le gouvernement en espagne
voulait restreindre les conditions
d'accès à l'avortement et moi je
militais avec femen et on avait décidé
d'organiser une série d'actions
individuelles dans plusieurs villes
européennes pour défendre le droit à
l'image et parce que oui j'ai été fait
même mais j'ai aussi été barbu j'ai
aussi osez le féminisme et j'ai presque
été chiennes de garde
s'il n'y a pas un seul féminisme mais
des féminismes moi j'ai commencé à dire
féministe vers l'âge de 16 ans quand
j'ai découvert de grandes intellectuelle
féministes comme par exemple l'écrivaine
violette leduc mais aussi la rappeuse
américaine queen latifah ou encore le
groupe de punk bikini kill qui est un
des pionniers du courant riot girl
après j'ai attendu quelques années
jusqu'à l'âge de 23 ans environ pour
m'engager dans différents mouvements
en fait j'en ai fait plusieurs parce que
à l'époque je cherchais une structure
qui englobe toutes les problématiques
féministe et à chaque fois j'avais
l'impression que les mouvements dans
lesquels j'allais s'intéresser à une
thématique seulement en particulier mais
du coup à osez le féminisme j'ai
découvert
un véritable laboratoire d'idées de
vrais débats de fond notamment avec leur
campagne osez le [ __ ] qui visait à
briser le tabou du plaisir féminin puis
ensuite avec la barbe pour celles et
ceux qui savent pas la barbe c'est un
groupe d'activistes affublées de barbes
postiches qui dénonce la sous
représentation ou l'absence de femmes
dans les lieux de pouvoir avec la barbe
donc j'ai découvert un un mode d'action
caustique et théâtrale qui me plaisait
beaucoup
comme leurs actions au festival de
cannes en 2012 qui dénonçait une
sélection de films 100% masculine et
ensuite j'ai rejoint femen parce que
leur mode d'action seins nus et leur
utilisation du corps comme un outil
politique me semblait très percutant et
aussi parce que je trouvais que l avait
un moyen en mettant le féminisme dans la
rue de le rendre à la fois plus
populaire est aussi accessible à toutes
et à tous et quand on y réfléchit
il n'y a pas un seul combat il ya
plusieurs combats et il n'y a pas la
femme en tant qu'entité mais des femmes
d'ailleurs sur des sujets comme le voile
ou la prostitution est ce qu'on sait
vraiment si c'est bien pas bien si on
est pour si on est contre on sait pas
vraiment d'ailleurs nous mêmes entre
féministes on a des points de désaccord
sur ces sujets là on a des points de
désaccords sur le port du voile on a des
points de désaccord sur la prostitution
on a aussi des points d accord sur la
gestation pour autrui est ce qu'il
existe plein de féministes différence il
existe des féministes voile et pour qui
religion et droits des femmes ne sont
pas incompatibles et qui considèrent que
le voile n'est pas un outil d'oppression
des femmes
il existe aussi des féministes lgbt ou
queer qui elle considère que le genre
est une construction et n'est pas un
fait naturel
il existe également des féministes des
afro féministes qui elle pense que les
femmes noires et afro descendantes sont
à la fois victime de sexisme et de
racisme et qu' elles sont souvent un peu
les oubliés du féminisme mainstream il y
a aussi ce qu'on appelle les féministes
essentialiste donc elle qui sont
convaincus du fait qu'ils aient des
spécificités féminines comme par exemple
le l'instinct maternel ou l'empathie
il y a aussi des féministes
universaliste comme simone de beauvoir
qu'on ne présente plus qui elle pense
que en dépit de nos différences
biologiques entre femmes et hommes
ça ne justifie pas la domination
masculine il y a encore des féministes
écologistes qui elle estime qu' il y a
un lien entre l'oppression des femmes et
la destruction notre planète
enfin voilà il ya plein de féminisme
différent parce que au cas où vous
l'ignoreriez toutes les femmes ne pense
pas de la même façon
donc voilà du coup aujourd'hui moi je
suis féministe freelance comme ça je
choisis les combats que je veux les
projets que j'ai envie de défendre et ce
qui me corresponde le mieux
par exemple en novembre 2015
j'ai créé contrecoup qui est une
compilation de douze femmes artistes qui
chantent contre les violences faites aux
femmes et tous les bénéfices du disque
ont été reversés à l'institut en santé
génésique qui est un centre basé à saint
germain en laye qui accueille et oriente
des femmes victimes de toute forme de
violence
il ya un an j'ai aussi lancé madame rap
qui est le premier site dédié aux femmes
dans leur âme et qui vise notamment à
créer des ponts entre hip hop et
féminisme féminisme avec un s au pluriel
pour moi c'était important de montrer
que contrairement aux idées reçues et à
tous les préjugés qu'on peut avoir
le rap n'est pas la musique la plus
misogyne qui existe n'est pas la musique
la plus homophobes qui existe et que
même certaines rappeuse sont de
véritables exemples d'hommes power man
féminin en fait je me suis aussi rendu
compte que
être féministe c'est pas forcément faire
des manifestations ou scandé des slogans
par exemple je pense que le lard ou la
culture peuvent être des biais beaucoup
moins clivant et - frontaux pour
exprimer une pensée féministe
quand on voit certaines artistes comme
la rappeuse de nicki minaj
il y avait qu une image hyper sexualisée
entend réinvestir la sexualité des
femmes noires aux états unis où la
cinéaste française céline sciamma qui
elle va visibiliser des femmes qui ne
sont pas en général dans la société où
l'écrivaine nigériane crime ananda a dit
fille qui elle prône un féminisme
inclusif toutes ces femmes sont
féministes à leur manière et elles le
sont de manière complètement libre et
détaché de tout enjeu politicien
elle propose des choses elles font
avancer les choses et jamais elle
n'oppose les hommes et les femmes parce
que que les choses soient claires le
féminisme ça n'a jamais été et ce n'est
pas une lutte contre les hommes c'est
une lutte contre le patriarcat
c'est à dire des codes intégré qui dicte
notre société et être féministe c'est
juste se dire ok je remets cette norme
dominante en question et je réfléchis à
un moyen de les déconstruire de la
déconstruire et de reconstruire une
société et un monde plus équitable
en fait voilà
franchement je pense que c'est juste ça
pour moi le féminisme c'est juste se
dire comment faire pour que on se traite
toutes ces tous de manière égale et
comment agir dans ce sens que quand on y
réfléchit il ya plein de manières
différentes d'être féministe on peut
être une femme entrepreneur qui montre
sa propre boîte
une mère célibataire qui mène de front
sa vie privée sa vie professionnelle et
tout le reste
une femme qui choisit de ne pas avoir
d'enfant et qui le clame haut et fort
une femme qui a été violée et qui décide
de raconter
mon histoire qui raconte son viol pour
inspirer d'autres femmes victimes
également à briser le silence et à se
réparer ça peut être aussi être
lesbienne et faire son coming out pour
là encore inspirer d'autres femmes et
devenir une sorte de rôle modèle pas de
toute façon le féminisme doit être
inclusif c'est vraiment quelque chose
que j'ai réalisé il ya quelques années
en me disant voilà pour que ça marche
en tout cas il faut vraiment que ça
englobe toutes les personnes minoré dans
la société
que ce soit les femmes les lgbt qu il y
a
les personnes racisées les handicapés
les rondes les ronds les jeunes les
moins jeunes les pauvres toutes les
religions et les athées bien sûr et les
hommes aussi peuvent être féministe à
leur manière ils peuvent agir de manière
féministe par exemple un patron qui
décide de payer de la même manière ses
employés femme et ses employés homme ou
un père qui décide de poser sa journée
pour aller chercher son enfant malade à
l'école pour que sa femme reste au
travail ou encore un homme en réunion
qui a conscience d'occuper tout l'espace
et de parler tout le temps et qui
choisit de se taire pour laisser les
autres femmes prendre la parole sont
juste des exemples mais tout ça ce sont
des comportements qui sont déjà
féministe le problème ce ne sont pas ces
comportements
c'est le terme féministes qui est encore
qui porte encore aujourd'hui une
connotation péjorative
moi je le vois bien par exemple dans des
dîners ou dans des soirées ou quand je
dis que je suis féministe
il ya certaines personnes qui se crispe
pas tous heureusement mais certaines se
crise et me prennent tout de suite pour
une espèce d'hystérique misandre
castratrice et frustré souvent alors que
quand je dis la même chose autrement
quand je dis que je me bats pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
tout le monde trouve ça trop cool trop
génial trop rock'n'roll et je passe un
peu pour mère teresa ou batman alors il
faut arrêter d'avoir une définition
aussi simpliste du féminisme est
vraiment
acceptez nos féminisme au pluriel donc
dans toute la richesse et dans toute
leur diversité
et pour que le terme féminisme ne soit
plus un gros mot
il faut que tous les féministes s'assume
par exemple fin ce soir dans cette salle
je suis sûr qu'il ya plein de féministes
qu'une fois qu'ils ignorent encore soit
qui n'assume pas cette appellation pour
que les choses changent il faut que
toutes et tous ensemble on commence à
dire qu on est féministe mois dans vos
prochains dîners ou dans vos prochaines
soirées je vous demande pas de faire
comme moi et de vous balader seins nus
ou de montrer vos seins en signe de
protestation et de risque et
éventuellement une accusation pour
exhibition sexuelle
mais je vous demande juste de dire eh
bien oui moi aussi je suis féministe
merci
[Musique]